en el vídeo pasado comenzamos con una
matriz
y de ahí empezamos a preguntarnos acerca
de su espacio columna y nos dimos cuenta
que eso es para su columna era el
espacio vectorial generado por estos
cuatro vectores pero después nos
preguntamos estos vectores serán
linealmente independientes o
dependientes para ver si eran una base
del espacio columna y fue justo en ese
momento cuando utilizamos la información
del espacio nulo de la matriz porque si
el espacio nulo de la matriz contenía a
otro vector además del vector cero
significaba que estos vectores no eran
linealmente independientes lo que nos
hizo entender que podíamos prescindir de
alguno de estos dos vectores y de hecho
nos dimos cuenta que los vectores que
estaban asociados con las variables
libres es decir en este caso el tercer
vector y el cuarto vector eran los que
podíamos escribir como una combinación
lineal de los otros dos haciendo este
mecanismo que tenemos aquí en el cual le
dábamos a uno de estas variables libres
el valor de menos uno ya todas las demás
cero para que de tal manera podamos
despejar al vector asociado con nuestra
variable libre que nos quedaba y a los
otros dos como vectores
y con el apoyo de estas ecuaciones que
habíamos sacado aquí al lado encontramos
de una manera sencilla cómo expresar a
este vector que estaba asociado con
nuestra variable libre como una
combinación lineal de los otros vectores
y esta es una buena manera de resolver
este problema si nosotros nos fijamos en
combinaciones lineales de los otros
vectores sin embargo hay una manera
mucho más rápido de hacerlo recuerda que
lo que estamos buscando no es el espacio
vectorial generado por estos cuatro
vectores es decir mi espacio columna de
amd lo que quiero es encontrar cuáles de
ellos son linealmente independientes y
además generan todo el espacio columna
de amd es decir lo que buscamos una base
del espacio columna de amd y la forma
más rápida de hacerlo es lo siguiente
tomamos la matriz a y poco a poco lo
vamos transformando en su forma
escalonada hasta llegar a esta matriz
que tenemos aquí recuerda que esta
matriz es la forma escalonada de la
matriz a y a continuación quiero que te
des cuenta cuáles son las entradas
pivote es decir qué variables están
asociadas a mis entradas pivote mis
variables pivote esta columna éstas
a x1 mientras que esta segunda columna
está asociada x2 la siguiente x 3 y la
siguiente a x 4 que es justo lo mismo
que la matriz a en la matriz a la
primera columna está asociada a x1 la
segunda columna está asociada a x2 la
tercera a x 3 y la cuarta a x 4 por lo
tanto vamos a poder sacar conclusiones
la forma escalonada de la matriz a
porque aquí date cuenta que tenemos
entradas pivote es decir las entradas
que tienen un 1 en esa entrada y en cuya
columna todas las demás entradas tienen
0 y entonces una vez que encontramos las
entradas pivote nos damos cuenta de
cuáles son las variables que están
asociadas a estas columnas y esas son
nuestras variables private que en este
caso fueron x1 y x2 y ya con estas
variables pivote me doy cuenta que estos
dos primeros vectores columnas son mi
base de mi espacio columna y no es que
sea un prophète o no estoy haciendo nada
de magia en esto lo único que quiero que
te fijes es que estoy utilizando la
definición de variables pivote y
variables libres las variables libres
les podemos dar un cierto valor y por lo
tanto puedo despejar de aquí a mis
vectores
van a ser mi base de esta o más bien de
este espacio columna y lo mejor de todo
es que siempre podemos hacer esto en el
vídeo pasado y vimos un caso particular
sin embargo siempre podemos trabajar con
esta idea estos dos que son mis columnas
asociadas a aquellas variables que son
libres equivalen a estos dos vectores
columna que tengo aquí vectores columna
que están asociados a mis dos variables
que son libres y esto es como la parte
más sucia de todo el asunto cuando no
podría llamar las sucias como la parte
más entretenida de todo esto porque al
final con la forma escalada de la matriz
puedes obtener bastante información y es
que recuerda que las dos soluciones son
las mismas la solución de x igual a 0 y
la solución de la forma escalonada de la
matriz a por el vector x igual al vector
0 porque recuerda que el espacio nulo de
estos dos son iguales y por lo tanto
podemos darnos cuenta que estos dos
vectores columna que están asociados a
nuestras variables pivote son los
vectores que van a formar la base y
además son vectores linealmente
independientes y es por eso que
concluimos que
uno dos tres y el doctor 114 en este
caso particular obteníamos que eran
justo la base de mi espacio columna de a
y bueno ya que tenemos esta fase del
espacio columna de la matriz a como lo
podemos visualizar en r3 ya tenemos
estos dos vectores a este conjunto con
estos dos vectores y como podemos
visualizar al espacio vectorial generado
por estos dos vectores así que como te
das cuenta que tenemos tres componentes
entonces cada uno de estos vectores
existe en r3
por lo tanto déjenme dibujarte aquí un
espacio en tres dimensiones
voy a suponer que estas mujeres x estos
ni de qué recetas este de aquí es mi eje
de las diademas era un poco mejor esté
aquí es mi hija 10 este de aquí es mi
caídas x esto se le hace estás y
entonces estamos en r3 y bueno el primer
vector tiene como componentes 123 así
que caminar 1 en x 2 en 10 y 3 a el z
así que vamos a caminar 1 2 y 3 por acá
aquí tenemos a nuestro primer vector
este de aquí está representado por este
vector de amarillo mientras que
3 1 1 y 4 estamos con un por acá este es
mi otro vector mi vector 11 4 y bueno
tarde los dibujos no sean lo mejor
posible no solo lo más preciso posible
no solamente quiero que te des una idea
de que cuando yo me tomo el espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores es un plano porque recuerda que
cualquier punto de este plano lo podemos
ver como una combinación lineal de estos
dos si nosotros nos tomamos una
combinación lineal de este y de éste
vamos a generar un vector que nos dé
este punto de aquí y si yo quiero un
punto más alejado pues también voy a
encontrar no sé tal vez múltiplos de
estos vectores tales que que al hacer
una combinación lineal con ellos obtenga
también un vector que esté en ese plano
y me dé ese punto por lo tanto ahora lo
que yo quiero ver después la ecuación de
este plano sería muy bueno entenderlo y
recuerda que la ecuación de un plano las
acabamos como el vector normal deben
ponerle mejoras y el vector normal punto
un vector que esté en este plano vamos a
llamarlo el vector x y justo este vector
me va a servir bastante para definir mi
plano y después le teníamos que quitar
un punto o un vector en este plano es
decir voy a suponer que éste
no voy a tomar el vector 123 así que el
vector x menos el vector 123 y como el
vector normal es un vector perpendicular
al plan entonces esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 y con esto vamos a obtener la
ecuación de este plano que tenemos aquí
y para esto como vamos a encontrar en
nuestro vector normal hay que ser un
poco de memoria porque en varios vídeos
ya habíamos visto cómo encontrar un
vector normal que por cierto lo voy a
dibujar aquí voy a suponer que este es
mi vector normal y existe una forma de
encontrar este vector normal con el
producto cruz de dos vectores que
existirán en nuestro plano y está
perfecto porque aquí ya tenemos dos
vectores que viven en este plano por lo
tanto vamos a tomar su producto cruz de
estos dos vectores y así vamos a
encontrar a un vector normal el cual me
va a servir para definir mi plano el
vector normal va a ser entonces el
vector 123 mi primer vector de mi base
cruz el vector 114 que es mi otro vector
de la base y cuánto es esto pues bueno
según la definición del producto cruz
para obtener la primera componente del
vector resultante eliminábamos estos
componentes y nos tomábamos 2
otro 8 menos 3 por 1 3 2 por 4 8 menos 3
por 1 3 en la segunda componente nos
elimina vamos de estas segundas
componentes y estábamos tentados a decir
1 por 4 menos 3 por 1 sin embargo
recuerda que la segunda componente de mi
vector resultante de este producto cruz
nos tomamos lo inverso es decir 3 por 13
menos 4 por 14 3 menos 4 recuerda que
estoy yendo vimos en varios vídeos que
cuando nosotros tomamos la segunda
componente de este efecto resultante
nosotros lo que hacíamos era cambiar el
orden o dicho de otra manera a este
misma componente multiplicada por menos
1 pero en fin cuando nosotros nos
queremos la tercera componente
eliminamos las terceras componentes y
decimos uno por uno menos dos por uno en
el sentido cotidiano en el sentido que
siempre utilizamos aquí no pasa nada y
después me queda 8 menos 3 53 menos
cuatro menos 11 - 2 - 1 y una vez que ya
tenemos este vector normal pues tenemos
este vector normal para cualquier vector
que esté en este plano es decir para
cualquier combinación de estos dos
vectores por lo tanto
puedo tomar este vector normal para
seguir con mi definición del plano que
es el vector normal punto x menos el
vector 123 así que déjame ponerlo aquí
el vector normal que es el vector 5
menos 11 el cual lo acabamos de
construir con el producto cruz de estos
dos vectores de la base ya este punto el
vector x que bueno voy a suponer que es
el vector x y z es mi forma más fácil de
poner un vector xx de z porque recuerda
que estamos en tres dimensiones y aquí
es mi eje x el eje x 7 - en uno de estos
dos vectores puede ser cualquiera de
estos dos voy a tomar el vector 1 2 3 y
esto igualado a cero porque tenemos un
producto punto de dos vectores normales
así que vamos a hacer las operaciones y
a continuación que me queda el vector 5
- 1 - 1 punto el vector
x menos 1 recuerda que hay que estar
cada una de las componentes y en menos 2
z menos 3
y todo esto igualado a cero y bueno pues
vamos a hacer la definición del producto
punto y que me queda pues es sí
por x1 más pero bueno más x menos es
menos porque es menos 1 entonces me
queda menos 1 que multiplica al menos 2
menos uno que multiplica a z menos tres
esto igualado a cero y si de aquí
distribuimos cada una de estas
constantes me va a quedar que 5x menos 5
- más 2 menos por menos me da más +2 y
después me quedaría - z3 menos 73
esto es igual a cero y si te das cuenta
más 2 3 menos 5 se van estos 0 y por lo
tanto mi ecuación de mi plano que me
estoy buscando es 5x
10 - zeta igual a 0 ya que tengo un
plano que por cierto este plano es mi
espacio vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores de mi base o dicho de otra
manera es mi espacio columna de todas
las combinaciones lineales de estos dos
vectores que formaban mi base que era el
espacio columna de a ahora están
representados por este plano quien por
cierto date cuenta que este plan no pasa
por el origen es decir contiene el punto
cero
pues si nosotros sustituimos a x a jay-z
por 0 cumplimos la igualdad y esto tiene
todo el sentido lógico del mundo porque
habíamos dicho que el espacio columna
era un sub espacio válido y todo sub
espacio válido debe de contener el
vector 0 por eso en este caso este plano
está completamente en lo correcto pues
contiene al punto 0 0 0
así que ya aquí tenemos a este plano que
es el espacio vectorial generado por mis
dos vectores de mi base de mi espacio
columna de amd y ahora lo que quiero
hacer es llegar al mismo resultado pero
de una manera completamente distinta así
que vamos a empezar con esta matriz
déjame copiarla y pegarla y vamos a
tratar de llegar a lo mismo así que a
copiar y a pegar y entonces no no esto
no es lo que yo quería es decir yo
quería lo inverso déjenme vuelve a
hacerlo déjame tomar esto de aquí y me
estoy tomando a esta matriz am y creo
que no va a quedar justo lo que quiero
hacer que no es que esté jugando con tu
tiempo lo que quiero es que quede lo
mejor posible
déjeme copiar y pegar y perfecto
y aquí tengo mi matriz así que déjenme
bajarla para acá y entonces te decía lo
que quiero hacer en este final de este
vídeo es obtener lo mismo solamente que
de una manera distinta porque lo que
hicimos ahorita fue un buen
procedimiento partiendo de los dos
vectores de la base de este espacio
columna de a lo que hicimos fue tomarnos
un vector normal el cual salió del
producto cruz de mis dos vectores que
eran mi base del espacio columna de amd
y después nos tomamos el vector x ya z y
le restamos cualquiera de estos vectores
que están en mi base de mi espacio
columna de a porque recuerdan que lo que
estoy tomando es un vector que exista en
el plano que esté sobre el plano y bueno
de hecho para que este lector sea
perpendicular al vector normal que me
estoy construyendo y esto hace que sea
igual a cero y de aquí puedo obtener la
ecuación de mi plano y de hecho aquí
debería ser un paréntesis como una nota
a todo lo que estaba construyendo pues
este vector normal sale del producto
cruz de estos dos vectores que estaban
en mi base porque estos dos vectores que
serán mi base no solamente representan
un punto en el plano sino que cada uno
de estos dos vectores que estaban en mi
base son vectores que están en mi plano
pues de hecho lo que buscamos es el
espacio vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores y por lo tanto estos dos
sectores deben de estar en el plano o
también otra forma de saber esto es que
mi vector 00 está también en un espacio
vectorial generado no es así y si está
en el vector 0 0 y también está al punto
el cual llega a mi vector entonces mi
vector también están en este plano y es
justo por esa razón que cuando yo me
tomo dos vectores de este plano y
calculó su producto cruz me da el este
vector normal que es un vector que no
solamente está fuera del plano sino
además es un vector que es perpendicular
al plano y por lo tanto es perpendicular
a cualquier vector del plano a cualquier
combinación lineal de estos dos peruanas
déjame tomarme la matriz am y ahora
vamos a buscar el conjunto de todas las
equis que cumplan y dejemos poner de
esta manera a x donde x es un miembro de
rn donde x es un miembro de rn y ahora
voy a definir el siguiente otro
junto el siguiente conjunto de las veces
de los vectores ves tal vez que cumplan
que x sea igual a b y además ve exista
bueno en este caso déjame ponerlo así y
x debe de existir en rn bueno voy a
buscar todas las veces que cumplan esta
ecuación así que por qué voy a hacer es
tomarme a esta ecuación con nuestra
matriz a así que déjenme copiar y pegar
otra vez a esta matriz
para que yo pueda obtener así los
valores de 20 y mejor déjenme definir
primeramente a b b del visto de una
forma general va a ser un vector x 17
que te das cuenta es un vector que tiene
que estar entre 3 por lo tanto ven es el
vector x ya se está bien una vez que ya
tengo ave entonces déjenme copiar y
pegar la matriz
que por cierto llega a tener por aquí la
voy a poner aquí abajo y me voy a fijar
en a que multiplica al vector x esto
igual dado al vector b entonces la
matriz a va a multiplicar
x no no no espera mejor déjeme ponerlo
de la siguiente manera va a ser mucho
más rápido si lo escribo en su forma
aumentada a x igual a 0 de 1 a x igual
al vector bent y lo voy a escribir en su
forma aumentada para que la solución sea
mucho más rápida así que me voy a tomar
a la matriz aumentada con el vector ven
y quién es esto pues esto es lo mismo
déjame escribir aquí abajo que esta
matriz am y voy a aumentarla al vector b
el vector b es el vector x y z y
entonces lo que voy a hacer es a esta
materia que tengo aquí buscar su forma
escalonada es decir la forma escalonada
de la de la matriz aumentada a la matriz
y el vector b y bueno que me queda si yo
lo que quiero es escalonar a esta matriz
entonces lo primero que tengo que hacer
es dejar el primer renglón tal cual no
me voy a complicar ahorita con el primer
renglón el cual es el que tiene puros
unos entonces déjame ponerlo aquí 1
1 1 y aquí x muy bien y el segundo
vector lo que voy a hacer es tomarme y
me voy a tomar dos veces el primer
renglón menos el segundo renglón de esta
matriz es decir voy a reemplazar a mi
segundo vector que tengo aquí con dos
veces el primer renglón menos mi segundo
renglón de tal manera que me queda un
cero abajo y aquí me queda 2x menos 10
es lo que voy a hacer y entonces me va a
quedar 2 por 12 menos 12 0 después 2 por
12 menos unos 12 por 12 menos 4 - 2 y 2
por 12 - 3 - uno perfecto ahora lo voy a
fijar en el tercer renglón y si te das
cuenta en el tercero no quiero que aquí
que de cero por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme tres veces el primer
renglón y restarlo al renglón de abajo
es lo que me conviene creo que sí voy a
tomarme tres veces el renglón menos el
otro no esperas pero espera que estoy
haciendo mejor me voy a tomar el renglón
de hasta abajo el tercer renglón
tres veces el primer renglón es justo lo
que quiero menos tres veces el primer
renglón y que me queda bueno pues en la
parte aumentada z menos 3
es menos tres por una pues lo mismo que
04 menos tres por una es lo mismo que
uno uno menos tres por uno es lo mismo
que menos dos y dos menos tres por uno
es lo mismo que menos uno y pues sí
justo esto es lo que habíamos encontrado
en la matriz de arriba esto lo habíamos
hecho en el vídeo pasado o algo parecido
así que bien en aquella ocasión es decir
en el vídeo pasado lo que hicimos fue
reemplazar el y creo que fue sin mi
memoria no me falla el segundo renglón
menos el tercer renglón y es justo lo
que vamos a ver en el siguiente paso el
primer renglón bueno ahorita lo pongo
después tengo cero 1 - 2 - 1 y en la
parte aumentada es 12 x menos james y en
el tercer renglón lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme el segundo renglón menos el
tercer renglón para que todo esto se
cancele y que voy a obtener de esto
bueno primero voy a poner la parte
aumentada que es 2x
- z 3x porque lo que estoy haciendo es
tomándome la diferencia del segundo
renglón menos el tercer renglón y
entonces me queda 0 - 0 lo cual es 0 11
lo cual es 0 - 2 más 2 lo cual es cero y
menos 11 lo cual es 0 y entonces date
cuenta que aquí hay algo muy importante
la única forma de que haya solución de
que x sea igual a bien es que esta parte
de aquí me dé cero porque si esto que
está aquí no es cero supongamos que es 5
me quedaría 0 igual a 5 y eso no tiene
nada de sentido y por lo tanto como no
tiene sentido matemático entonces no
habría solución a esta ecuación a x
igual a b
la única forma en la aquellas soluciones
que todo esto que tengo aquí sea igual a
cero no puede ser cualquier otro número
tiene que ser igual a cero para que se
pueda cumplir esta ecuación que tengo
aquí arriba a x igual a b pues tiene que
cumplir la parte de aquí abajo y
entonces me queda que 2 x menos menos
713 x tiene que ser igual a 0
forzosamente pues no estoy tomando una p
para una vez válida para una vez que
esté o que sea un miembro del espacio
columna de esto para que sea un vector
válido tal que a x puede hacer este
vector o él o sea el posible valor que
podría tomar a x para alguna equis y
bueno entonces si agregamos me queda que
2 x 3 x es lo mismo que 5 x después me
queda menos y en menos z igual a 0 y
date cuenta que es exactamente lo mismo
a lo que llegamos ese rato nosotros nos
habíamos tomado el producto cruz de dos
vectores que estaban en este plano y con
esto encontramos a un vector normal
humberto que fuera perpendicular al
plano para que después nos tomáramos el
producto punto de este vector normal
menos un vector en el plano que lo
habíamos denotado así y después de hacer
un poco de álgebra llegamos a la
ecuación de mi plan esto en nuestra
primera forma de resolver el problema
nuestra segunda forma de resolver el
problema lo que hicimos fue tomarnos la
ecuación a x igual a b suponiendo que
existía en el espacio columna de amd y
trabajamos con la matriz aumentada hasta
que llegamos a que esto tenía que ser
igual a cero el producto
la única manera de obtener 0 es que esta
parte de aquí tenía que ser igual a 0 y
llegamos ya con esto a la ecuación del
plano y espero que esto sea bastante
satisfactorio para ti encontrar la
solución de un problema por dos maneras
distintas y además que logremos con el
álgebra lineal utilizar toda la
información que hasta este vídeo hemos
aprendido